-Performing "Liz,"
from the deluxe edition
of her album "Juno,"
please welcome Remi Wolf!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ She's a sexy little mama ♪
♪ Just like her
daddy taught her ♪
♪ She don't seem the same ♪
♪ Since she working
on the corner ♪
♪ I hope she don't fade away ♪
♪ Hope she find another lover ♪
♪ And it was Liz, Liz ♪
♪ She taught me how to live ♪
♪ Oh, it was Liz, Liz ♪
♪ She taught me how to give ♪
♪ It was Liz, Liz ♪
♪ She taught me how to live ♪
♪ Oh, it was Liz, Liz, Liz ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, baby ♪
♪ Oh, baby, baby,
ba-ba-ba ♪
♪ Ba-ba-ba-ba,
ba-ba-ba-baby, ha ♪
♪ She don't eat alone ♪
♪ And she goes home alone ♪
♪ Too much time alone ♪
♪ Time alone on the phone ♪
♪ And nobody, nobody,
nobody calls ♪
♪ Nobody, nobody, nobody calls ♪
♪ She gets lonely ♪
♪ And she wants to hold me ♪
♪ Oh, oh oh ♪
♪ But I don't hold things ♪
♪ No, I'm too lonely for that ♪
♪ And when troubling, troubling
troubling calls ♪
♪ Catch me vaping orange juice
outside of the mall ♪
♪ I get lonely ♪
♪ So I go shoplifting ♪
♪ It's better than sitting,
unh-unh ♪
♪ Crying in my kitchen ♪
♪ When nobody, nobody,
nobody calls ♪
♪ Nobody, nobody, nobody calls ♪
♪ Expect Liz, Liz ♪
♪ She taught me how to live ♪
♪ Oh, it was Liz, Liz ♪
♪ She taught me how to give ♪
♪ It was Liz, Liz ♪
♪ She taught me how to live ♪
♪ Oh, it was Liz, Liz, Liz,
L-i-i-iz ♪
♪ Liz, Liz, Liz,
oh-oh-oh ♪
Ha!
♪♪
♪ Oh, no-no-no-no, no-no-no,
no-no-no ♪
♪ No-no-no, no no ♪
♪ And I said yeah, yeah,
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah ♪
♪ Yeah yeah yeah,
yeah yeah yeah yeah ♪
♪ Ba ba ba ♪
♪♪
♪ Liz ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, come on.